[Music]
welcome to marketing analytics Series
where we teach practitioners about
Google Cloud marketing analytics
Solutions and showcase their use case
and business value in video one we
talked about the different ways you can
leverage Google Cloud to transform
marketing analytics in your organization
hi I'm Kelsey and for this video we'll
discuss how to break down marketing data
cells with bigquery I'll show you how
you can ingest in query data using
bigquery
if you are not familiar with bigquery
bigquery is Google Cloud's fully managed
cloud data warehouse that is designed to
help you ingest store analyze and
visualize data with ease
bigquery has built-in features like
machine learning geospatial analysis and
business intelligence which can help you
unlock new and impactful insights from
your data
bigquery also has an underlying
architectural Advantage by decoupling
storage and compute this allows for more
flexibility and allows it to scale
seamlessly
bigquery allows you to ingest the
plethora of data with ease you can store
data from different sources like Google
analytics Google ads sap Salesforce and
social media data into bigquery
you can also store a variety of data
types from customer data that will be
needed to perform analysis as well as
cost and operations data for making
smarter business decisions alongside
with other data
there are a few ways data can be
ingested into bigquery you can batch
load data into bigquery load sources
from CSV files external databases or a
set of logs stream data into bigquery
which allows you to continually and send
smaller batches of data in real time so
the data is available for querying as it
arrives this includes storage rights API
data flow and real-time replication of
sap data directly into bigquery you can
use bigquery data transfer service DTS
which is a fully managed service to
ingest data from Google SAS apps such as
Google ads external storage providers
such as Amazon S3 and transferring data
from data warehouse Technologies such as
teradata and Amazon redshift you can use
SQL to generate data and store the
results in bigquery as well
finally you can ingest data using
third-party partner Integrations this is
helpful for marketers because it allows
you to ingest data from various sources
in different types once your data is in
bigquery now you can query the data when
you run an SQL query in bigquery it
automatically creates schedules and runs
a query job
bigquery runs query jobs in two modes
interactive mode on demand queries are
executed as soon as possible and these
queries count towards concurrent rate
limit and daily limit
in batch mode this is when queries are
queued and started as soon as Idle
resources are available in the bigquery
shared resource pool which usually
occurs within a few minutes
finally you can get an augmented
understanding of that data when you use
Google Trends data for your analysis
bigquery has a large number of public
data sets to help bring additional
insights to your business
now let's bring this all together with a
quick demo
in this demonstration we are going to
set up our data sync from Google ads to
bigquery
then we'll run a simple query to see how
easy it is to aggregate our data using
bigquery
first let's create a data transfer
service job this simply schedules the
sync from our data between our ads or
analytics Platforms in our bigquery
project
to do this you'll need to collect your
relevant customer and account ID
information ahead of time
once you have this information in a
project setup go to bigquery data
transfers if prompted enable the API
next set up the transfer services from
the Google ad service to a new data set
in your project which can create from
the screen
that's it now that the transfer is set
up data will be refreshed on a scheduled
Cadence in your bigquery data set
after the first transfer has completed
you will have data in your bigquery data
set let's take a look in the console at
some sample data and how we can run a
quick query to see some aggregate
results
for this example we are looking at a
sample of Google analytics data this
includes things like clicks and events
from users
using table preview we can see a sample
of the data that has been loaded to see
what fields are available and what types
of data populate the fields
next we can run a sample query from the
console to aggregate some user accounts
before we run the query bigquery tells
us the approximate bytes that will be
scanned helping us understand how much
we will be built
once we execute the query we see the
results below and we can get the results
instantly for up to seven days
and there you have it now you know how
to ingest and query data using bigquery
if you're eager to learn more about
Google Cloud marketing analytics check
out the link below
if you enjoyed this video please make
sure to like this video and click the
Subscribe button to watch more videos
like this
[Music]